welcome to this video playing maroon c5
okay I'm from from Canada let's go for
this Lillian Russell evil yeah white
develop some with natural museum Bishop
e3 Queen d2 age five
h5 is on a bit down a bit uncommon looks
a bit strange to weaken a g5 like that
ok once I I'll start to prepare prepare
form Wow ok yeah i'll try to open the FL
ok Knight f3 is very natural move yeah
it's also good for let's not be too
sophisticated about it ok and now i
think ii 594 is the way to go go to d 6
16 not necessary you can play other
moves not acting like Queen f4 end and
submit them but grass haha yeah of
course no the physician i think is
already already a very bad for black
with various for various reasons okay
let's see here for i can also take yeah
i'll just take it
my attention was before to open up
inside okay I'll take that ending Trust
fixing the pawn and then night a four
and taking it here we go soaps and yet
another poor netted maybe m-maybe g5s a
move that term he tries to play possible
yeah it's not it's not really
threatening much g5 the night is simply
nice on c5 so let's put it down
this night only seven is especially
terrible that doesn't have d5 as a
square draw our third one of those guys
doesn't really know chess but knows
where the draw button is okay yeah I
have got I've got f7 NASA as a very
useful target and this is almost made if
I manage to take them now dito if it
takes on d to look at seven Bishop d7
look b7
yeah dan this should should end and
things I hope
rook f7 as it's basically double attack
night on c4 and the bashad the porn on
f7 Knight d2 row club f7 check rook t7
Dennis 96 meet Bishop d7 group p7
checking see Aiden and e6 was what I was
thinking and then a bishop moves rook c7
made and this should check should end
and the game I hope he's got this is
checkmate checkmate this one wasn't the
toughest after Bishop d7 the question is
if i should play reroute p7 or not this
is what i was thinking either i've got a
jacket made into and you behave minute
so then it's a first mate i forgot about
that did I was only thinking about him
of her goddess is wrong I didn't see it
I was thinking about this check but he
is God rook takes c5 which I'm not sure
is really winning tidus winning even
that is winning because of the maid
thread check yeah this is also when okay
but made it to his far more convincing
yeah he some he played too many moves
that just weaken the position h5 as one
of them it's really strange too smooth
it's doing nothing positive and just
weakens guarantee here this almost looks
up the others looks very hard to defend
already and now the dark square so very
weak yeah the CMOS 294 is too strong and
here yeah i was i was planning to play
before open up the Queen side but c4
just gives up the spawn
you know so we'll be doing opening a
disaster here thanks for watching